alex thank you
uh good morning uh so i should start by
saying that this is joint work with uh
uh five for gel head of geneto and
francis back who are also in paris and i
just want to do one short advertisement
um am i cutting several postdocs
for one or two years at economic
superior this is the view from our
office
uh
more or less and and so
if you're interested and it's over a
couple of years so if you're interested
or you think you're going to be
interested please send me an email i'm
very interested
um so
convex uh
relaxations for permutation problem
problems is a bit vague
and today i'm only really going to focus
on on two problems and the first of them
is seriation and seriation is very easy
to describe you have a matrix storing
similarity information so aij is the
similarity between variables i and j
okay
and you make one key assumption here
which is that the data has a serial
structure okay
meaning that well roughly speaking there
is a permutation of these variables such
that the similar
similarity matrix has a
is decreasing starting from the diagonal
so there is this explicit condition
we're going to say that
a i j
a pi i pi j is an r matrix after
robinson
if a pi i pi j decreases with i minus j
okay
so hopefully speaking this looks like
this
and the seriation problem is very easy
to describe you don't get this what you
observe is this
okay it's a random permutation of this
serial
similarity matrix and you need to
reconstruct this
okay
that's it
um so that's the first problem i'm going
to focus on the second is the continuous
one problem
so seriation is easy to understand but
in in fact it turns out that this is the
important one and they are they're
directly connected
okay and in in sorry in c1p so this is
abbreviated c1p you're given a zero one
binary rectangular matrix
and you want to reorder its rows or
columns such such that the the ones in
each hole
are
contiguous okay
so here the problem looks very much the
same you're given this matrix here
and you want to permute find the
permutation of the columns
such that what you get is something that
looks like this okay and here this is a
c1p matrix because all the rows have
contiguous ones
right
and the connection with seriation is
very direct if you compute c transpose c
d overlap matrix what you get is an r
matrix okay so this satisfies the
condition i just mentioned this
has a serial
structure okay so you have this result
from kendall in 69 which connects
the two
problems
okay any questions so far
so why is this important well uh in in
short shotgun gene sequencing for
example
what you really want to solve during
assembly is a c1p problem so how does a
shotgun gene sequencing works well we
don't know how to sequence long
sequences of genes so what happens is
that they're cut into small pieces about
400 base pairs
that number increases slowly over time
but roughly speaking that's the order of
magnitude
and and the genes are the genomes are
cloned multiple times so we get many
pieces from many different clone genomes
and and the point is then to reorder
this bunch of small reeds they're called
reeds
so that well you finally get you can
reconstruct a consensus sequence from
the small bits the reordered small reads
okay so that's shotgun gene sequencing
and why is it connected to the problems
i just mentioned
well
it turns out that reordering these small
reads is is solving roughly speaking
a c1p problem there's a limit of noise
etc but essentially when you have the
reads the small reads reconstructing the
full sequence turns out to be equivalent
to solving a c1p problem why well if you
get the sequences in the correct order
and you assume that the the length of
the reads doesn't vary too much
and you basically identify
in the reads small subsequences called
k-mers and plot everything in terms of
these k-mer positions
if you get the correct order then the
columns
of the reordered
k-mer versus read matrix will have the
continuous one property
okay
so basically reordering the reads from a
shotgun
gene sequencing
data set
amounts to solving a c1p problem okay
so
it turns out and this is one of those
rare miracles where at least in the
noiseless case we have an explicit
solution that there is a spectral
solution to this problem
and curiously enough it's it's not being
used in in gene assembly and i'm not
sure why but that
maybe we haven't discovered that it
doesn't work numerically but so far
experiments are very conclusive
and so it's very easy to describe it's
based on spectral clustering
so what you do is that you compute you
solve this problem that's essentially
computing the second
smallest eigenvalue of the laplacian of
the matrix a okay
and it turns out that if you compute the
corresponding eigenvector
well the order of the variables in this
vector
also gives you the the correct
reordering that makes a an r matrix okay
so you're given
a up to a random permutation you compute
it's it's a fiddler vector so the vector
you use in spectral clustering for
example
you look at the order in the variables
you reorder them and then you plug the
you use the same order to reorder the
matrix and voila it's in
r format so it has this nice serial
structure and it serves in particular
the c1p problem if you look at the
squared matrix okay
and so this this result the one i'm
citing here is due to these authors but
i'm pretty sure and i'm very interested
if you have references in mind i'm
pretty sure this is something that has
been rediscovered in in different forms
in different fields okay so it's
probably known somewhere else you may
have your favorite reference but at
least this one comes from one of the
science journals and it is dates back
from 98.
okay
so i i could stop here
but i'm not gonna
do that
and the reason why i'm not gonna do that
is uh that well the spectral solution is
nice um
it's very easy to get
a second
eigenvector it's something you can solve
at web scales
pagerank roughly does the same thing
so so that's really satisfying but it's
only in the noiseless case and there's a
small region uh controlled by the size
of the spectral gap where the spectral
solution is stable so you're fine but
then the question is what if your data
is really noisy what happens beyond the
perturbative regime
for the second eigenvector okay so
that's one question what if the noise is
high
suddenly the spectral solution stops
working and it's not clear what you get
okay and how to control the quality of
the solution that's left
that's one point noise the second is
what happens if you have additional
structural information so i don't know
anything about gene sequencing but
clearly the process is a little bit more
complex than what i just described and
in particular you have side information
so you know that for example certain
pairs of genes should be kept close
together etc so people know where
certain genes should be so that you have
a lot more information than just the
similarity between pairs of reads
and the question is
how do you incorporate that information
in the spectral solution it's not clear
at all how to do that and this
information is key to resolve
uncertainties in the way things should
be reordered because for example in gene
sequences there are lots of repeats and
so on which really mess up the process
so there's structured noise in gene
assembly
yes
uh there are degeneracy issues that can
be handled so you have multiple
solutions etc but the the paper i'm
citing has really worked out all the
details of what happens in those cases
too that they're rare but they do happen
if your matrix is more structured than
natural similarity data so that that
that's well understood too and there are
ways of storing the data efficiently so
that really that part of the problem is
is kind of nicely closed okay
i mean unless you have more imagination
um so the the question here is we have a
solution
uh we have the spectral solution but we
don't know in fact the kind of the
problem we're solving so we don't have
in particular an objective to tell us
this solution is better than this one or
something like that or we get a solution
out of the spectral we want to do a
little bit more greedy optimization we
don't know what to optimize so we need
to reformulate seriation as an
optimization problem
okay
and so creation to to get an idea of
what to do it's it's easy to think in 1d
and in one day it's very easy to
formulate
an optimization problem which will
serialize the data so okay so you know
this very basic result if you have an
increasing sequence a1 a n
okay if you solve this minimization
problem over all permutations uh so the
scalar product between a i and a
permuted version of b
well there's a trivial solution you just
set pi such that b pi is decreasing okay
so one the original sequence goes like
this and the one that minimizes
basically moves in the opposite way
and um so that's that's one d you so
solving seriation in one's 1d is easy
you just minimize something that an
objective that looks like this in 2d
it's a little bit more complex but the
idea is roughly the same you can write a
problem that is suspiciously close to
what you you're trying to do called the
twosome problem and it's mentioned in
the atkins paper
but they don't really make the
connection
in twosum you minimize this quantity
here overall permutations of rows and
columns of the matrix a and basically
what you do is that you have this
quadratic penalty on the distance to the
diagonal okay so you heavily penalize
terms uh that are way outside of the
diagonal and you don't penalize so much
terms that are close to the diagonal
which is what you want to do right and
you minimize that over permutations
and so typically this will tend to put
the large similarity terms close to the
diagonal and the small ones outside so
it seems to do what we want and the key
question is this is nice because it can
be written in terms of the laplacian of
the matrix a we've seen a lot of
laplacians yesterday so that's all good
news
uh we we sort of suspect this is going
to be what we want to solve the of
course the the the annoying news is that
this is an np complete problem uh not as
a which is different from the 1d
scenario but
the question is is this really solving
seriation
and the answer is for certain matrices a
yes
okay
and um
so the way to look at to to see that a
very brief proof proof sketch is just to
decompose the matrix a so you have the
similarity matrix uh and it turns out
that the a very nice way uh of the for
the computing of the decomposition of
the matrix is to decompose it in terms
of cut matrices and the definition comes
from a paper by a friezen canon on
matrix approximations
and cut matrices are simply squared
constant
sorry a constant block
symmetric block matrices okay zero one
it's an elementary block and we're gonna
try to write our matrix a objective
matrix a as a combination of cut
matrices okay
and why do why are cut matrices a good
choice here well it turns out that the
objective can be written in terms of the
laplacian so this is our
twosome objective it can be written in
this format
and
if the matrix a is a cut matrix
then basically what you're computing
here is a variance
okay
and so you're trying to find a
permutation of the
vector y that minimizes the variance
if you assign uniform probability
weights to all the coefficients
okay
and why is that exactly what you want
well if you look at solutions with
minimum variance
so here it's i'm minimizing the
objective for cut matrix uh with a
constant block between variables five
and eight okay so it's this block here
minimum variance solutions
tend to have continuous contiguous
points inside um
so all the the indices are contiguous
here
okay
so
in fact in
in particular this means that the vibes
are correctly reordered they're in
sequence okay
and this is what you want so as soon as
the vibes are not in sequence so there's
a there's a gap here the variance
increases
so at least we know by this sort of hand
waving argument
that on
cut matrices the twosome problem
actually solves the steriation problem
we serialize the the variables uh inside
the block corresponding to the cut
matrix okay
very roughly speaking and and then the
idea is well the
so you have these two results
if you start from a pre-r matrix you can
show that any r matrix or pre-r matrix
which is a permutation of an r matrix
can be written as a combination of cut
matrices okay
so you have the decomposition you want
and you can completely formalize the
result i just displayed which is that
the solution of a twosome minimization
over cut matrices are has contiguous uh
consecutive
indices okay so it does what you want it
serializes the data
and um
it turns out that if you decompose if
your matrix can be decomposed in terms
of cut matrices
uh
then well you're done because
uh you know that the solution where all
the vibes are correctly reordered inside
the block
is optimal for each particular
minimization sub problem corresponding
to each cut component
and your objective is just a sum of
components and for each of these
components the the consecutive solution
the one where the vibes are in the
correct order is optimal
so you're optimal for each little sub
piece so you have to you have to be
globally optimum and that's it okay
so basically what you can show
is that when the matrix is pre-r
if you compute its square
then the two sum
and the seriation problems
so the two-sum problem will solve the
seriation problem on the squared matrix
a so the only requirement here i'm
focusing on our matrices but the only
requirement here is that your matrix has
to be written as a combination of cut
matrices okay
so at least now we have
one combinatorial problem
which actually solves the seriation
problem
and and so why do we care why is this
important well first there's a nice
side effect which is that we now have a
polynomial time spectral solution to the
twosome problem for certain types of
matrices a okay
so that's nice
the original paper by atkinson and
others
mentions both problems but they don't
really show the connection
make the connection explicit
but more importantly here
in practice at least
we can now write seriation as a
combinatorial optimization problem
uh and uh the idea is then to write a
convex relaxation for twosome and
creation
why well the spectral solution scales
very well but we know it's not very
robust it sort starts to fail outside of
the spectral perturbative regime where
the noise is smaller than the spectral
gap
and it's not flexible so the idea here
is that we have additional structural
information about the solution we want
to include this information in the
optimization problem we're solving and
then hopefully relax that problem solve
it and get a solution that is more
robust
okay
and that's very easy to do
you can write dn the set of doubly
stochastic matrices so these are
matrices whose rows and columns sum to
one and which have non-negative
components
and um
this turns out to be the convex hull of
the set of permutation matrices which is
the set we really care about
you can also notice that the set of
permutation matrices is the intersection
of the set is the set of matrices that
are both doubly stochastic and
orthogonal
and so we're going to solve a very large
quadratic program that looks like this
okay
and i'm not going to
let you look very long at this slide and
try to infer what's going on um i'll try
to explain piece by piece what's going
on so of course the constraints here so
our main variable is this matrix capital
pi
if all goes well and that never happens
uh pi is a permit permutation matrix so
it encodes the uh permutation okay so
it's just a permutation of the identity
um
and then well you have this objective
here and the main constraints and i'll
say a few words about these so in the
objective looks like this
and this is only a sort of more compact
notation for this
and what we do here is that we know
we can solve
the two sum problem serve the seriation
problem when y i is equal to i
okay and and we sort of suspect and we
haven't shown it yet but it's kind of uh
source of natural that if you perturb
a little bit the sequence y i equals i
our result our equivalence between two
sum and variation still holds and you
get a slightly different relaxation and
it turns out that at least numerically
it's a good idea to average the
objective over several choices
of these
monotonic sequences index sequences so
we we start by sampling points y i where
y i is equal to y
to i sorry plus a small noise epsilon
and we average the objectives okay so
it's a bit of a hack but it tends to
improve things a bit
and so that's nice and then there's an
additional
trick
which is to say well our objective is
convex we minimize it so we get a point
somewhere in the center of the set of
doubly stochastic matrices the nice
permutation matrices we care about are
on the edge so we want to push
our matrix as make our objective as
concave as possible and and it turns out
that we can add at least a small concave
component to it which improves things a
bit it's another hack but it seems to
work
um and and that's just it's a very
natural penalty because basically among
all doubly stochastic matrices the the
rotations
hence the permutation matrices have the
highest forbidden stone so we're just
trying to maximize the forbidden norm
but we need to to maintain the convexity
of the objective
and there is an explicit bound on mu
that
basically keeps the objective convex and
it's simply based on the eigenvalues of
y and the laplacian okay
so that's the objective we're just
solving two sum but for a different set
of objectives
and um
we have this extra penalty to try and
concavify the objective that's it
and and one important thing so what
about the constraints now
for the constraints well there's just
the the fact that pi is doubly
stochastic plus one extra hack and this
is really
extremely important
and it's easy to forget
so if you think about the seriation
problem you actually have always two
solutions two monotonic solutions who
solve the problem to optimality in the
noiseless case at least one where the
sequence is monotic monotonic sorry is
increasing and the
second one where the sequence is
decreasing okay and they're both equally
good
and that's it's it's not an issue if
you're solving trying to compute the
spectral solution and so on it's just a
matter of signs okay but as soon as you
write a complex relaxation for the
problem when you have these degeneracies
you're in trouble because every time you
have multiple solutions in a convex
relaxation all the solutions in the
middle should be good too
the ones you really care about are the
extreme points but the ones you get are
the points in the middle
so if you have degeneracy in a convex
relaxation you should immediately remove
it to improve the quality of the
relaxation this is easy to forget and it
makes a huge difference numerically okay
so the last constraint is simply here to
say that among all the possible
degenerate solutions of the seriation
problem the one we care about is the one
that is monotonically
increasing okay i'll
practice on that
um
anyway so
uh this is a key constraint it makes a
huge numerical difference but it's just
there to lift the degeneracy okay
so this relaxation is at this point
simply a hack uh we we don't have
approximation bounds but it's it's kind
of easy to
go further than this it's it's not very
tight right it would just relax
permutation matrices as doubly
stochastic matrices the problem is a
large qp numerically there is some hope
because it it has a nice structure so
it's not so bad but we can do a lot
better than that
so i've just said that permutation
matrices are matrices that are both
doubly stochastic and orthogonal
and so we can add the constraint that
the matrix we are looking for is
orthogonal and try to relax it and that
turns out to be a somewhat classical
problem it shows up in the process uh
formulation where you're trying to do uh
alignment you're trying to align images
for example or in cryo-em
reconstruction you have a lot of these
alignment problems so the the there's a
long list of results on on how to relax
those uh um
quadratic constraints okay those
orthogonality constraints sorry
and they're based on a very simple
observation which is that when you have
a constraint like this q transpose q is
equal to the identity
well it's an orthogonality constraint
but it's also if you look at the matrix
q as a vector
it's also a quadratic constraint on the
vector q okay
and so well if you have a non-convex
quality constraint on q you can simply
lift it using the traditional
semi-definite relaxation technique okay
and and the good news is that in some
cases like proquest and so on you can
show very very tight almost nearly
dimension independent approximation
ratios for these relaxations so square
root of log n square out of logan is
more or less six okay so
so the approximations ratios are really
good unfortunately from a numerical
point of view this is a complete
disaster because think about it the
matrix is uh has
roughly n square variables in it
you're going to consider that it's a
vector
lift it as an sdp
so what you get is an sdp of dimension n
square
and when you if you try to solve that
using an integral point method for
example the complexity you get is n to
the power nine okay
that's not exactly a tower of
exponentials but for practical purposes
it's it's a bit tricky okay it doesn't
work beyond dimension 10 also
so
so these relaxations are very nice for
getting bounds
but but in practice and in all the
examples we first we've tried them and
they don't seem to make a huge
difference in the problem we've
considered
and also from a practical point of view
they're
completely out of reach numerically but
it's much easier once you have an sdp
etcetera to quantify the approximation
quality and we don't have anything yet
if you use the doubly stochastic
constraint alone okay
so i apologize for the lack of
approximation bounds
but
if necessary we can prove them but
numerically it's going to cost you okay
but so more importantly in practice here
we can add constraints
and at no cost numerically
and solve semi-supervised seriation
problems so
you know in these gene sequencing
experiments for example that one one
read should be before another or that
two reads should be close to each other
etc well every one of these linear
constraints on the order just shows up
as a linear constraint on the matrix
capital pi okay
so every time you have additional
structural information about the
permutation you're looking for you just
add a linear constraint to the problem
okay
so that's
one very important fact just add linear
constraints if you have information and
again for gene sequencing you do have a
lot of structural information the second
thing i need to say is okay you solve
the problem
typically you're still doing convex
minimization over the set of doubly
stochastic matrices so
most of the time you get something
inside
so you get a doubly stochastic matrix
that's not a permutation and the
question is how do you get a permutation
out of a doubly stochastic matrix so
there are many things you can do it's
actually tractable to compute the
nearest permutation matrix to the doubly
stochastic matrix you're given that's
called the hungarian algorithm but that
works but not so well and it seems that
a very simple trick which is to generate
monotonic random monotonic sequences
apply pi
and recover the order works quite well
actually pretty well and it's very cheap
you just compute
matrix vector products at each iteration
okay so it's of course exact if your
matrix is a permutation matrix most of
the time it's not it's a doubly
stochastic matrix but you still get an
ordering at the end by computing d u
where u is this random monotonic vector
again okay
and so
basically what we do in practice we
solve the convex relaxation and then we
sample a lot of candidate solutions
based on that a very simple
randomization procedure okay
so
that's about it
uh so we get a large qp but it's not so
bad because it's easy to solve with with
no numerical effort whatsoever problems
of size 100 or 200. you have this very
nice pre-processing technique using the
spectral algorithm so it turns out that
we can solve relatively large problems
okay so i'd spend the rest of the time i
have showing numerical experiments to
try to get you interested then it's
early in the morning so uh graphics help
and so i'm gonna measure performance of
these solutions using
several metrics uh so remember here
we're going to be comparing permutations
the true one and the the resulting one
so
well how do you measure the distance
between two permutations or the
similarity between two permutations
there are many ways to do so
one is simply to compute the pearson
correlation between the two index
sequences okay that's called spearman's
rule
the second is to compute something
called candlesto so we're gonna take two
pairs of points in each of the sequences
and we're going to say that they're
concordant if one is smaller than the
other so both components are smaller or
both components are larger okay
and the candle toe is simply the ratio
of the number of concordant pairs minus
the number of non-concordant pairs
divided by well the number of pairs okay
and
that's another measure
they don't behave this one is a little
bit more sensitive
one of the the the objective of our work
was to get an objective to measure the
quality of a seriation solution beyond
what you get from the spectral solution
so one way to keep track of the
performance of a method is simply to
compute the two-sum objective that
combinatorial problem i just mentioned
okay
and finally if if you know you're
solving a seriation problem you can
simply count the number of
r constraints that are violated okay so
you know that on an r matrix the
coefficients should be decreasing as you
move away from the diagonal
and you you can basically count the
number of times this
condition is is not satisfied at a
certain number of indices and that's
another measure of performance okay
so for historical reasons i'm going to
start with this example which is a
relatively cheerful
you're trying to reorder
chronologically graves okay so what you
observe and this is the original
motivation for canada's work on the on
on ciation
so you have a matrix which represents
it's a zero one matrix and and it's a
matrix that's uh 70 by 59 and it's
artifacts
versus graves
so they're trying to
use the presence or absence of certain
artifacts in graves to order them okay
meaning that all the graves from a
certain period should have roughly
speaking the same artifacts okay and so
the idea here is that
you want to solve the problem
so that the matrix will be reordered and
have a
continue continuous one the c1p property
over rows okay so you permute the
columns which define the chronology
so that uh the
presence or absence of an artifact is is
contiguous uh in in the rows okay and so
on the left is scandal's
original solution and that's 1971 so
it's either an army of students or paper
and pencil but it's pretty impressive
right it's already a permutation problem
in dimension
59 so
and and the data is quite noisy and
we'll see that this solution which was
done manually does quite well
this is the solution you get uh using
spectral ordering and it looks good too
and this is the solution you get by
semi-supervised variation and i'll say a
few words
on where the structural information
comes from
there are interesting things to say
about the numerical results
so here it's the four measures of
performance i mentioned before so uh
scandal toes spearman's row the two-sum
objective and the number of violated are
constraints
for kendall solution the spectral
solution the qp relaxation and the qp
relaxation with additional structural
information
so where is the structural information
coming from here it's very simple we
compute a solution and then we
read from the solution some pairwise
ordering constraints and we add these
constraints to the problem so we
generate information out of nothing but
it seems to help which is kind of
interesting so in particular if you add
constraints structured constraints from
the original candle solution you do a
little bit better than candle but
kendall beats all the other
instances okay
and so this is an interesting scenario
where the semi-supervised solution does
better than the original solution even
though you haven't added additional
information you just plug hard
constraints coming from the origin the
first solution so it's a bit bizarre
but with combinatory optimization
everything is bizarre
anyway so that's the first example
another example is markov chains
so you observe random permutations from
a markov chain so you again you lose the
chronology
and so here it's a simple gaussian
markov chain
written
in this way
and what you know is that the mutual
information matrix decreases with the
distance between i and j
when the variables are ordered according
to the true markov chain
that's a it's called the information
provocation inequality or something like
that it has a name like that it's in
cover and thomas
and that means that the mutual
information matrix in our case is a
pre-r matrix meaning that there's a
permutation of it which recovers the
correct chronology
which turns out to have this nice r
property okay
and so
well we can
we can do some simulations so this is a
very simple markov chain
the true mutual information matrix uh we
obviously randomly permute
the observations
and this is the solution you get from
the
spectral
algorithm
and this is the solution you get from
the qpr accession and with the qp you
can try many many instances because
there is a random element to it and just
keep the one with the best objective so
this is the best out of 100 experiments
and you see that it's
the way it's um
it looks very similar to the the true
one that's a
kind of nice and intuitive example
we
we have absolutely no idea how what this
could apply to so if you have a good
application for this i'm really
interested because it looks cute
it's it's our markov chain so it should
be fairly universal but we don't know
what to do what to do with it okay
and finally
so yeah yeah i should
show you numerical information so
you can clearly see that everything
breaks apart
in the spectral method as soon as the
noise is larger than the spectral gap
and
that the effect of structural
information is is pretty strong
it starts to be pretty strong even if
you don't have too much of it okay so
this is candlesto between the true
markov chain ordering the spectral
solution the qp and the qp with some
structural information okay and what you
see obviously is that when you have no
noise the theory tells you that the
spectral solution is exact and you see
that candlestick is one it's a
correlation uh and you see that the qp
solution is not so good okay
same thing here as soon as you add
structural information in fact a lot of
it it starts to get better but it's
relaxation so it's not exact
and
if you keep so what we do here is that
we compute the mutual information matrix
using uh
very few samples so we have a lot of
noise or a lot of samples so we don't
have too much noise and we calibrate the
number of samples so that we get we stay
inside the perturbative regime so the
noise is smaller than the spectral gap
and then
we remove samples so that at one point
we leave the spectral regime okay
and so
well when the noise is within the
spectral gap the spectral solution is
still stable and works quite well and as
soon as you move out the spectral
solution completely collapses okay
um
so
that's that's nice and you see also that
this is monotonic in the number of
pairwise information you get
uh observations you get and so um
it seems that the semi-supervised
version works
okay and to finish i'll show you results
on dna
and again
because you use spectral the spectral
solution as a preprocessing step you can
solve these things on on very large uh i
mean very large it's your definition on
mine but it's it's a no it's a non-issue
to solve this on large data sets so for
example here it's a uh we have a
read a shotgun gene sequencing read data
set on chromosome 22
and we get 250 000 reads and we get the
spectral solution in in two seconds okay
so without any effort numerically
speaking and we use that as a starting
point and the idea here is that for
genes we're gonna start by using the
spectral solution it's gonna get some
parts of the sequence right
and as soon as
some parts of the sequence are right you
can collapse these uh this part of the
problem and the problem shrinks okay
so you reorder using spectral your some
of the sequence is is correctly
assembled you shrink it and you you're
now left with a much smaller problem and
you repeat until your problem becomes
small enough and it actually takes one
iteration but it could take more
so that you can use the qp relaxation
and as soon as you use the qp relaxation
you can add structural information that
you you get
and finish the problem so this is what
we do
and so how does it work you don't know
the correct order of course but you know
when you got it right when you look at
the
overlap matrix so that should be an r
matrix so it should have the r property
and so
this is basically a plot of the overlap
matrix corresponding to the spectral
solution on this chromosome 22 data and
you see that some sections are perfectly
assembled because well
if you look at the corresponding
overlap matrix it has the r property
and then for other sections there are
issues coming from for example some
parts of the sequence being repeated and
so on okay so this is a zoom on two
regions because the matrix is 250k by
250k
and so this is what happens when you do
spectral as a pre-processing step and
then use the qp relaxation with some
structural information to finish the job
okay the spectral solution so this is a
plot of index for the recovered points
versus index in the true solution so if
it zigzags you've got some points wrong
and if it's a line then you're fine you
got the correct ordering it's a very
direct way of visualizing the the
solution
and so this is a spectral solution so
you can see that
some large segments of the genome are
correctly assembled you can immediately
shrink them collapse the problem over
this segment so everything the dimension
shrinks significantly and then for
others there is some ambiguity okay
and so if you
start from the spectral solution showing
the problem and try to reorder the
segments using the qp with some
structural information coming from the
sequencing process this is what you get
okay
and so i'm not at all an expert on on on
as genome uh shotgun gene sequencing
assembly but most of the algorithms used
at this point for denovo sequencing are
heavily combinatorial and local people
from these graphs etc and they build the
solution piece by piece locally and and
i haven't found a reference where
they've tried the spectral solution to
see how well it works
and
and so well it seems that it's kind of
spectacular to see that this very naive
procedure uh works so well so we're
gonna try to run it on full genomes
there's no numerical limitation to do so
there's a bit more preprocessing but
that's it the main computational
bottleneck is computing the overlap
matrix the r matrix of similarity
information uh but that is naively
parallel so it's an issue okay and the
spectral solution is almost instant
immediate and the qp
well typically you start it when the
problem has dimension 100 or 200 so it's
an issue and it seems to work um
relatively well so hopefully this will
go somewhere so just to conclude um
we've shown the equivalence between the
two-sum combinatorial problem and
seriation for a certain type of matrix
matrices a
okay
we have a very simple qp relaxation for
semi-supervised seriation so seriation
with some side information and it seems
to have relatively good performance on
shotgun gene sequencing okay
open problems so approximation bounds in
the case where you only use the doubly
stochastic constraint i think it's
fairly easy to generalize existing
results when you add orthogonality
constraint and relax it but numerically
this is quite
challenging
and it would be very interesting to try
to quantify the approximation quality of
the simple doubly stochastic collaxation
okay
but it's not clear exactly how the
randomization procedure we have now can
be analyzed and so on so if you have
ideas i'm really interested
of course we would like to solve the
large-scale qp and exploit structure
efficiently to get really large
instances instead of the the ones we do
now
and also it's not clear what the impact
you can choose many similarity measures
you can generalize the results to
unimodal
matrix matrices with unimodal columns
and rows instead of just as binary
and so clearly the similarity measures
you use have an impact and we don't know
exactly how to pick them okay that's it
thank you very much
yes
yes
yeah yeah yeah
when you have a noise
i don't know but typically you would
want to play with if so for the shotgun
sequencing experiments you typically get
errors in the reads and so on so one way
to make the problem more robust is to
use different
similarity measures than just overlap
okay and and then what you get is
essentially unimodal matrices uh so you
have the same result you use a different
matrix product but roughly speaking the
spirit is exactly the same and that
tends to be more robust
so that would help i think in a noisy
case and i agree that the the other
results you mentioned are probably
faster to solve the c1p problem but it's
not clear what kind of behavior
tolerance to noise they have
yeah yeah and it's the same thing with
all the classical techniques to solve
the
genome assembly problem they're heavily
combinatorial and since you have noise
this is really tricky
yes
the greedy
greedy basically
it would be greedy right
yeah so for gene sequencing you have
oh okay so uh is there a reason why we
ignore the simple greedy procedure where
you take a candidate and then look for
the nearest point in the cloud okay of
other remaining points is that your
question of speaking okay so the idea is
that that's greedy and it works if your
sequence is noiseless and does not have
repeats
and the key difficulty in genome
assembly is that you some sequences of
the genome are repeated because were
very poorly designed and so
basically if you do that you can branch
out to an assembly that's completely
incorrect and then you're stuck
okay so in the gene assembly not only do
you have noise because you get you make
some mistakes in reading base pairs you
also have structured noise in the
problem that's almost
adversarial because of some of these
segments of the genome that are
repeated and so you really need to look
at a global objective to overcome this
limitation and add structural
constraints otherwise the problem is is
unsolvable
okay so that's why greedy fails i think
it's the structured uh
noise
yes
does it hurt your computation time to
make it sort of flatter
versus you find that it does help even
though you're right uh we haven't
checked you mean is it longer to solve
when we concavify a little bit i
probably but i
it helps a lot the quality of the
solution so you you're closer to a
permutation matrix that's supposed to be
good it's a very heuristic statement but
that seems to work but in terms of
computing time i don't know
thanks thank you